The year is 1861, and America is deeply disconnected. From east to west, our nation is the biggest it has ever been, and yet construction of the Transcontinental Railroad won't even begin for another two years. On a whistle-stop trip to take the oath of office, it had taken the newly elected Abraham Lincoln 11 whole days to travel from Cincinnati to Washington, D.C. by train. Only a genius or a madman would think it was possible to cut that trip down to just one night. Thabius Sobieski-Kulencourt Lowe.
时间是1861年，当时的美国正处于深深的割裂之中。从东到西，我们的国家达到了空前的辽阔，然而横贯大陆的铁路建设还要再过两年才会开始。在乘火车前往宣誓就职的途中，新当选的亚伯拉罕·林肯花了整整11天时间才从辛辛那提到达华盛顿特区。只有天才或疯子才会认为有可能把那趟行程缩短到仅仅一个夜晚。塔比乌斯·索别斯基-库伦库尔特·洛。
That was his full name. His parents gave him names. They pulled out of obscure novels. This is author and journalist, Jack Hitt. Thadius Lowe was one of these sort of huckster promoters, not quite a con man, part carnival barker, part inventor, part scientist. And Thaddeus Lowe was. wore those eccentricities for everyone to see.
那是他的全名。他的父母为他取了这些名字。他们是从晦涩的小说中挑出来的。这是作家兼记者杰克·希特。塔迪乌斯·洛就是那种投机取巧的推销员，不太像个骗子，有点像嘉年华叫卖者，有点像发明家，有点像科学家。而塔迪乌斯·洛正是如此。他把这些古怪之处展现得淋漓尽致，让所有人都能看到。
He had long flowing hair and that sort of mustachio that was popular. And that time, he also had what was then called a chin puff. So he had that sort of wizardy look, right? The look of a great eccentric man of science of that time. And it was this chin-puffed man of science who had come up with a new scheme that involved traveling from Cincinnati to Washington, D.C., in a single night carried in the basket of a gas bag. We called it a hot air balloon, but at the time, it was also known as a gas bag. Gas bags had been around for a while at this point.
他留着长长的披肩发和当时流行的一种八字胡。那个时候，他留着当时被称为“下巴撮”的胡子。所以他看起来有点像巫师，对不对？一副当时伟大的古怪科学家的模样。正是这个留着下巴撮的科学怪人，想出了一个新计划：乘着气囊的吊篮，在短短一个夜晚从辛辛那提飞往华盛顿特区。我们称之为热气球，但在当时，它也被称为气囊。到这个时候，气囊已经出现一段时间了。
A lot of them just going up and coming back down, tethered to the ground. That was how the first balloon flight had happened near Paris almost 80 years earlier. But in the decades that followed, no one had really discovered what to do with the I think every new technology enters that sort of liminal period where it's either a novelty gimmick, it's going to become silly putty, or it's going to become the computer. Yeah. All right? And the balloon at this time was sort of in that strange sort of twilight space.
它们中的很多只是升上去然后落下来，用绳子拴在地面上。大约80年前，世界上第一次热气球飞行就是在巴黎附近以这种方式进行的。但在随后的几十年里，没有人真正弄清楚该如何处理……我认为每项新技术都会进入那样一个过渡期：它要么是个新奇的小玩意，要么会变成橡皮泥，或者会变成计算机。是的。对吧？而在当时，气球就处在那种奇怪的灰暗空间里。
Yeah. It was seen as both like sort of magical and mystical. I mean, we have always wanted to escape Earth's clutches. And the balloon was the first actual real practical way. that we could do it. But it was also seen as incredibly dangerous, and people did float away on these things, and nobody ever heard from him again.
是的。它既被视为某种神奇而神秘的东西。我的意思是，我们一直想要摆脱地球的束缚。而气球是我们能够做到这一点的第一个真正切实可行的方法。但它也被认为极其危险，人们曾乘着这些东西飘走，就再也没有人听到过他们的消息。
They were incredibly dangerous. They already seemed dangerous to me now. Like, I would never go in one. And remember, this is hydrogen gas. This is the Hindenberg. Okay? So, you know, we have this really clean, lovely floating image of a hot air balloon.
它们极其危险。现在对我来说，它们看起来已经很危险了。比如，我绝不会坐那种东西。记住，这是氢气。这是兴登堡号。好吧？所以，你知道，我们对热气球有着非常干净、可爱、漂浮的印象。
And one reason maybe why we should fill them gas bags is because these were really the beta models of the modern hot air balloon. You know, the very balloon smelled like it came out of the pits of hell. Gas bags were so dangerous, in fact, that King Louis XVIth suggested that if balloons were going to go up untethered, then convicted criminals should be the ones to pilot them. Yet despite the gas bag's considerable flaws, people were searching for its ultimate purpose. But Thaddeus Lowe knew what the real purpose would be. He wanted to invent an overnight mail carrier service, sort of the FedEx of 1861.
我们或许应该把它们称为气囊的原因之一是，这些确实是现代热气球的测试版模型。你知道，那气球闻起来就像是从人间地狱里出来的。事实上，气囊是如此危险，以至于路易十六国王建议，如果气球要不受束缚地升空，那么应该由被定罪的罪犯来驾驶它们。然而，尽管气囊有相当大的缺陷，人们仍在寻找它的最终用途。但塔迪乌斯·洛知道真正的用途会是什么。他想发明一种夜间邮件投递服务，有点像是1861年的联邦快递。
And he believed, as did others, that up in the upper atmosphere, there was supposed to be this consistent west to east wind. This is not necessarily even close to true, but it was the theory at the time. And if he was right about the wind, then all Thaddeus needed to achieve his dream was money. And so on April 19th, 1861, he set up an evening of fundraising in what was then known as the ballooning capital of America, Cincinnati. Cincinnati became sort of the balloon beginning center. I mean, a lot of balloonists would come there and try out there. Balloons, the Cincinnati Gazette actually had hired a Mr. J.C. Bellman as their first official, quote, balloon editor? That's a golden age of journalism right there. You have a balloon editor on staff.
他和其他人一样相信，在高层大气中，应该存在着这种从西向东持续稳定的风。这甚至不一定接近事实，但这在当时是一种理论。如果他对风的判断是正确的，那么塔迪乌斯实现梦想所需要的全部东西就是资金。因此，在1861年4月19日，他在当时被称为美国热气球之都的辛辛那提筹办了一个募款之夜。辛辛那提成了某种热气球运动的始发中心。我的意思是，很多热气球飞行员会来到那里并试飞他们的气球。《辛辛那提公报》甚至聘请了J.C.贝尔曼先生担任他们的第一任官方，呃，“热气球编辑”？这简直是新闻业的黄金时代啊。你们的员工里居然有一个热气球编辑。
You know, when they fired the balloon editor, Roman, that's when the decline of print journalism began. And it was in this boom of balloon journalism that Thaddeus Lowe wanted to demonstrate to investors that his gas bag, An aircraft he named The Enterprise would take him from Cincinnati to Washington, D.C. in a single night. There were several days of festivities, like Lowe gave an address at the opera house and there were parties and so on. But finally, this big night comes. He shows up in classic sort of American style. He's in a stovepipe hat, the kind of Lincoln War. He's in a broadcloth coat, which is we would recognize it as like tuxedo tails.
你知道，罗曼，当他们解雇热气球编辑的时候，正是印刷媒体开始衰落的时候。正是在这股热气球新闻业的热潮中，塔迪乌斯·洛想要向投资者证明，他的气球——一架他命名为“企业号”的飞行器——将带他在一个夜晚从辛辛那提飞往华盛顿特区。那里举行了好几天的庆祝活动，比如洛在歌剧院发表了演讲，还有派对等等。但最终，这个重大的夜晚来临了。他以典型的美国风范亮相。他戴着一顶烟囱帽，也就是林肯戴的那种。他穿着一件宽幅呢大衣，也就是我们认出的那种燕尾服。
And late toward the end of the evening, his assistants come in and say, the winds are moving east. It's time to go. So he gets in there with like, you know, bottles of water and food and a brand new wet, inky copies of the Cincinnati paper so that when he arrives, he can prove that he was in Cincinnati that morning. Oh, yeah, yeah. And he cuts loose and then poof, he just disappears into the night. Just like that, Thaddeus vanished. He wouldn't be seen or heard from again until the next morning, by which point he hoped to have landed on the mall in Washington, D.C. In reality, Thaddeus wouldn't see the sunrise behind the unfinished Washington Monument.
到了深夜临近结束时，他的助手们走进来对他说，风向正在转向东方。是时候出发了。于是他带着水瓶、食物以及印有墨迹的《辛辛那提报》的全新湿润报纸上了气球，这样当他抵达时，他就能证明自己那天早上还在辛辛那提。哦，对，对。然后他解开绳索，接着“砰”的一声，他就消失在夜色中。就这样，塔迪乌斯消失了。直到第二天早上，人们才会再次看到或听到他的消息，而他希望到那时自己已经降落在华盛顿特区的国家广场上。现实中，塔迪乌斯并没有看到未完工的华盛顿纪念碑后方升起的日出。
In fact, he wouldn't even get particularly close. But Thaddeus Lowe's flight from Cincinnati would prove to be a defining moment in his life. Instead of taking him to the nation's capital, his foul-smelling balloon would instead lead him to a series of new discoveries, discoveries that continue to shape America to this very day. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars. And today, the Enterprise Gas Bag
事实上，他甚至没有飞得特别近。但塔迪乌斯·洛从辛辛那提的这次飞行被证明是他生命中的决定性时刻。这个散发着恶臭的气球并没有把他带到国家的首都，反而引导他走向了一系列新的发现——这些发现至今仍在塑造着美国。这里是由99%隐形节目（99% Invisible）与BBC工作室联合制作的《100件物品中的美国历史》。我是罗曼·马斯。而今天的主角是“企业号”气球，
and the birth of the American obsession with pushing higher and higher. It's 4 a.m., and Thaddeus Lowe is now alone in the wicker basket of his gas bag, somewhere far above since an hour. out of Ohio. But he isn't exactly sure where. It's even sort of a mystery to him as to what he would find when he, you know, went up this high
以及美国人对不断向更高处探索的执念的诞生。现在是凌晨4点，塔迪乌斯·洛独自一人坐在气球的柳条篮里，身处俄亥俄州辛辛那提上方极高的某个地方。但他并不十分确定自己在哪。对于自己在这个时候升到这么高空，
at night. Of course, remember, this is before the invention of the electric bulb. So when night fell, it was a night. So he could look down a mile or two or three and of course he saw nothing. And up above him, he just saw stars. Yeah. And some moon, right? And while he's up there, He's doing his tests and measurements in this little basket beneath this hydrogen gas field balloon. And out here at the edge of the then-known universe for humans, he discovered the oddities of being there. He is just humming along at these amazing speeds that no one had ever, you know, reached at this time. But he's stunned to discover that, you know, inside his little basket, he's not moving at all. He says
究竟会发现什么，他甚至觉得有点神秘。当然，记住，这是在电灯泡发明之前。所以当夜幕降临时，那可真是黑夜。因此他向下望去，看两三英里或更远，当然他什么也看不见。而抬头上望，他只能看到繁星。是的。还有一些月亮，对吧？当他在高空中时，在这颗由氢气填充的气球下方的小篮子里，他正做着测试和测量。在这个当时人类已知宇宙的边缘，他发现了身处那里的奇特之处。他正以惊人的速度呼啸前行，这是当时任何人从未达到过的速度。但他惊讶地发现，在自己的小篮子里，他竟然一点也没有在移动。他说，
Everything around me was perfectly quiet and still So still that I could have carried a lighted candle Without any protection And I let loose sheets of paper Without fear of them being disturbed The reason for this may not be quite clear to my readers But I was floating width As well as in the undisturbed atmosphere
我周围的一切都是绝对的安静和死寂。寂静到我可以拿着一支点燃的蜡烛，而不受任何保护。并且我可以松开手中的纸张，而不用担心它们被气流干扰。我的读者可能不太明白其中的原因，但我当时不仅随同不受干扰的大气在向前移动，
There was not the slightest sense of motion whatsoever So Loz sort of discovers that he's not only in the wind. He is the wind, right? Heading, who knows where. Thaddeus had embarked on a kind of journey that nobody had ever been on before. He was suspended in the inky black sky, all on his own. And in that darkness, Thaddeus had no way to orient himself. He wouldn't know where he was until the sun came up.
而且与之融为一体，没有感受到哪怕一丝一毫的运动。所以洛有点发现，他不仅仅是在风中。他自己就是风，对吧？不知要驶向何方。塔迪乌斯踏上了一种前无古人的旅程。他独自一人悬浮在墨黑的天空中。在那片黑暗中，塔迪乌斯没有任何办法辨别方向。直到太阳升起，他才会知道自己在哪。
the next morning he comes down and sees an open field and there's a man at a plow and he lets off some gas and comes down low enough that he can shout out what state is this and the man he looks left he looks right far off into the woods but it doesn't make any sense that the sand would come from the woods and does it see anybody and he keeps looking at round. Lowe shouts it again. What state is this? And he just keeps looking. And Lowe later realizes, of course, the man didn't look up because no one had ever looked up before. Why would you look up? Sound didn't come from up. Up hadn't been invented yet. But the guy, the guy does shout, he finally just shouts towards the woods because he wants to answer. And he says, Virginia.
第二天早上，他降落下来，看到一片开阔的田野，有一个农夫正在扶犁耕地。他放掉一些气球里的气体，降落到足够低的高度，大声喊道：“这是什么州？”那个农夫向左看看，向右看看，一直看到远处的树林里，但声音从树林里传来这根本说不通，而且他没看到任何人，于是他继续环顾四周。洛再次大喊：“这是什么州？”而农夫只是继续张望。洛后来意识到，当然了，那个人没有抬头看，因为以前从来没有人抬头看天。你为什么要抬头看？声音又不是从天上来的。那个时候“天上”这个概念还没被发明呢。但那个人，那个人终于大喊出声，他只是朝着树林的方向大喊，因为他想回答。他喊道：“弗吉尼亚！”
And then Lowe thinks, well, I don't want to stop here. So he unties one of his bags and lets the sand out. And it falls near the man who finally looks up. And then when he sees what's above him, he goes running off into the woods to hide. The man runs for his life. But Lowe decides to keep going, figuring he must still be close to D.C. In reality, he was much further south. So he travels on a little bit further.
然后洛心想，好吧，我不想在这里停留。于是他解开其中一个压载沙袋，把沙子放了出去。沙子落在那个人附近，那个人终于抬起了头。接着，当他看到头顶上方是什么东西时，吓得转身逃进树林里躲藏起来。那个人吓得仓皇逃命。但洛决定继续前进，心想自己离华盛顿特区应该还不算太远。实际上，他已经到了更南边的地方。于是他继续往前飞了一小段，
and he finally does come down into a field in Unionville, South Carolina. Now, you remember, I mentioned to you, April 19, 1861, that date might ring a little familiar in your head because April 12th, one week before, is the firing on Fort Sumter. Thadius had found himself in the deep south, only one week after the first shot of the Civil War. Did Thaddeus know that the Civil War had started a week before,
最后他终于降落在南卡罗来纳州尤宁ville的一个田野里。现在，你们还记得我向你们提到过的那天吗——1861年4月19日，这个日期你们脑海中可能会觉得有点耳熟，因为就在一周前的4月12日，萨姆特堡爆发了枪战。塔迪乌斯发现自己身处深南地区，而此时距离内战的第一声枪响仅仅过去了一周。塔迪乌斯在踏上这次旅程的一周前，
he left on this trip? They did, but of course, and this is something he's going to find out in the next like 24 hours. You know, the shot had been fired, you know, but no life had been lost. So yes, the civil war had started, but the civil war hadn't started, right? It was kind of like a, you know, maybe this will just go away. And I think most people sort of believe that, but as Thaddeus is about to learn, that was increasingly not the case. Despite not really believing in the war yet, the people of South Carolina were still deeply suspicious about Thaddeus and his intentions. Something about him just didn't seem quite right.
知道内战已经爆发了吗？他们知道，但当然了，这也是他将在接下来的大约24小时里发现的情况。你知道，枪声已经打响了，但还没有人命丧黄泉。所以是的，内战已经爆发了，但内战又好像还没真正爆发，对吧？这有点像是一种“也许这事儿过会儿就会过去”的心态。我想大多数人都这么认为，但正如塔迪乌斯即将了解到的那样，事实越来越并非如此。尽管南卡罗来纳州的人们还不愿真正相信战争已经打响，但他们对塔迪乌斯及其意图仍然深表怀疑。他身上的某些特征看起来就是不太对劲。
Once he landed and all these men with guns showed up, he tried to convince them that he was, you know, a human. Because he wrote at one point, he says, many of them thought that I was the inhabit of some ethereal or infernal region who had floated to Earth to do them damage and injury. Yeah, but it was just Cincinnati. Right. Thaddeus takes some crackers and butter rolls out of his basket, thinking they might show that he's human. And finally he pulls out a few rubber hot water bottles. He cut one open.
一旦他着陆，所有这些拿着枪的人都出现了，他试图说服他们自己是个……人类。因为他在某处写道，他说道：“他们中的许多人认为我是某个虚无缥缈或地狱世界的居民，飘落到地球上来给他们带来破坏和伤害。”是的，但这里只是辛辛那提啊。没错。塔迪乌斯从篮子里拿出了几块饼干和黄油面包卷，以为这些能证明他是个人类。最后他又掏出几个橡胶热水袋。他割开了一个，
They'd frozen, right, being out of very, very cold, cut one open to show them that, you know, this was just ice inside. But of course, he later realized that was the worst thing you could have done because one of them immediately said, How could anyone but a devil put so large a piece of ice through so small a place as that nozzle? That's an excellent point. You got to give it to him. He was not convincing anybody that he was a normal human.
它们都冻住了，因为外面非常非常冷。他割开一个给他们看，你知道，这里面装的只是冰块。但当然，他后来意识到那是他能做的最糟糕的事情，因为其中一个人立刻说道：“除了魔鬼，怎么可能有人把这么大的一块冰塞进那么小的管嘴里去呢？”这是一个绝妙的观点。你不得不佩服他们的逻辑。他根本没法让任何人相信他是个正常人类。
Despite this, Thadius does somehow manage to persuade them, but that only creates more problems. So, of course, they all thought he was some kind of Yankee spy. So at this one, he's been arrested by these planters and these four. out in the field, and he's being taken into Unionville to go to jail because he's a spy. And when he gets there, they can't put him in it because it's already packed with, quote, abolitionists. Okay. Wow.
尽管如此，塔迪乌斯还是设法说服了他们，但这只带来了更多的问题。所以，毫无疑问，他们都认为他是什么北方联邦的间谍。此时此刻，他已经被这些种植园主和四名当地人逮捕，关押在一片开路上，并被带到尤宁ville去坐牢，因为他们认定他是间谍。当他到达那里时，他们却无法把他关进去，因为监狱里已经塞满了所谓的“废奴主义者”。好吧。哇。
Okay. So they take him to the hotel where they're going to put him in a room under armed guard. Now, they do recognize, because he's on the top hat and tails, that he might be a man of some means or someone of importance. and somebody does finally find some local sort of erudite person who has heard of that he is low and so he vouches for him and keeps him out of jail for the day but word has spread and there's like a lynch mob there and they're they're out to get it um and so he is his balloon is put on a train and then he separately has to go back to first kentucky and then Cincinnati and then back east and he sort of describes like
好吧。于是他们把他带到一家酒店，把他安排在一个房间里，由武装看守监视着。现在，他们确实意识到，由于他戴着高顶礼帽、穿着燕尾服，他可能是一个有钱有势的人，或者是个重要人物。终于有人找来了一位当地有点学问、听说过塔迪乌斯·洛的人，于是这个人出面为他作保，让他免受一天的牢狱之灾。但消息已经传开了，那里聚集了一群像是私刑暴民的人，他们是来找麻烦的……因此，他的气球被装上了火车，而他则必须分头先乘车返回肯塔基州，然后到辛辛那提，再回到东部。他这样描述当时的场景：
you know, these trains are packed and it's full of people escaping the South. I mean, the war, and he realizes the war is on. Soldiers are going both ways. Yeah. Everyone was getting ready. Because suddenly, as Thadius realized, it was war. Yeah. Heading home on that train, Thadius knew his scheme had failed.
你知道，这些火车挤满了人，全都是从南方逃难出来的人。我的意思是，战争开始了，他意识到战争真的爆发了。士兵们朝着两个方向调动。每个人都在做准备。因为突然之间，正如塔迪乌斯所意识到的那样，战争爆发了。坐在回程的火车上，塔迪乌斯知道他的计划失败了。
His balloon had come down nearly 400 miles southwest of his intended destination. In fact, he was almost exactly as far away from Washington as where he began. So the FedEx idea was. dead. And on top of that, the world had changed overnight. The war had started. And so if he was ever going to see his aeronautical ambitions come true, Thadis Lowe needed to go back to the drawing board. So how does that is pivot? Pivot's beautiful. He just needs a new stunt and he comes up with it. And it's only a few weeks later. So that was April. Now it's June 18. He has come to D.C. with his gas bag. And he's inflated it right outside the White House and nailed it to the ground.
他的气球降落在距离预定目的地西南方向近400英里的地方。事实上，他距离华盛顿的直线距离，几乎和出发时一模一样。所以联邦快递的构想泡汤了。最重要的是，世界在一夜之间变了。战争爆发了。因此，如果他想让自己的航空梦想成为现实，塔迪乌斯·洛就必须重新回到图纸前。那么，塔迪乌斯该如何转型呢？他的转型堪称完美。他只需要一个新的噱头，而他确实想出来了。那仅仅是几周后。所以那是四月。现在是6月18日。他带着他的气球来到了华盛顿特区。他在白宫外给气球充了气，并把它固定在地面上。
But this time he puts a telegraph system in the basket and runs a wire straight down to the ground where he has a little messenger boy. And he sends the first airborne telegram and the return address is balloon enterprise in the air, June 18th, 1861, to his excellency, Abraham Lincoln, president of the United States. you know, this balloon is right outside his window. And so he taps out a telegraph message. The first part of it reads, I can see nearly 50 miles in diameter. The city with its girdle of encampments presents a superb scene. So it gets a little poetic, but, you know, he is a con man too. I mean, he's a, he's a carnival barker, too. So he adds in a little LinkedIn sort of jibber japper. It goes on to say, And acknowledging indebtedness to your encouragement for the opportunity of demonstrating the availability of the science of aeronautics in the service of this country. I am your excellency's obedient servant.
但这一次，他在篮子里安装了一个电报系统，并拉了一条电线直通地面，地面上站着一个传信小男孩。他发出了第一封空中电报，发信地址是：“空中的企业号气球，1861年6月18日”，收件人是：“美国总统亚伯拉罕·林肯阁下”。你知道，这个气球就在林肯的窗户外面。于是他敲击发报机发送了一则电报。电报的第一部分写道：“我能看到直径近50英里的范围。这座城市环绕着军营，呈现出一幅壮丽的景象。”所以这段话变得有点诗意，不过呢，他本质上也是个骗子。我的意思是，他也是个嘉年华叫卖者。所以他加进了一些林肯风格的俏皮话。电报接着写道：“并对您的鼓励表示感谢，感谢您提供机会，让我们得以在这个国家的服务中展示航空科学的实用性。我是阁下听话的仆人。”
So that message goes into the White House and believe it or not, Lincoln invites him to dinner. Because Lincoln, it turns out, is a early adopter. He's really into new tech. Yeah, yeah. And so he goes into the White House and he says they talked late into the night. But he explains like, you know, we should use them for spying capability. This would be a novel purpose for the gas bag, one that made the whole going up and coming back down thing actually useful. So Thaddeus lays out his sales pitch to Lincoln.
这封电报被送进了白宫，信不信由你，林肯邀请他共进晚餐。因为事实证明，林肯是个早期采用者。他非常热衷于新技术。没错，没错。于是他走进白宫，他说他们长谈到深夜。但他解释说，“你知道，我们应该把气球用于侦察能力。”这将是气球的一个新奇用途，能让这种上升再下降的把戏真正变得有用。于是，塔迪乌斯向林肯阐述了他的推销说辞。
He explains like, you know, I think we can get up there and we can we can see things that no one has ever seen before. And understand in those days, Intel was gathered by putting a, you know, one or two or three people. on individual horses and just sending them off into the woods to sort of scout. Right, right. And Lincoln got it. Yeah. He gave Thaddeus a letter of introduction to Lieutenant General Winfield Scott, who was at that time the headman of the war.
他解释说，“你知道，我认为我们可以升上高空，我们可以看到前人从未见过的景象。”要知道，在那个年代，情报的搜集靠的是派出一两名或三名骑马的人，把他们派进树林里去进行侦察。确实如此。而林肯听懂了。是的。他给塔迪乌斯写了一封介绍信，介绍给当时军队最高负责人、陆军中将温菲尔德·斯科特。
So he has this letter of introduction. He goes over there to Winfield Scott's tent. And his assistant, the orderly, says, well, the general's busy right now. So Lowe comes back a couple hours later. He says he's still busy. Yeah. Comes back a few hours later and says, he's at lunch. Comes back a little while later, he says, the general is now sleeping.
于是他拿着这封介绍信，来到了温菲尔德·斯科特的帐篷外。他的助手、值星官说：“将军现在很忙。”于是洛几个小时后又回来了。助手说将军还是在忙。没错。过了几个小时他又回来了，说将军在吃午饭。又过了一会儿回来，助手说将军现在正在睡觉。
So he realizes, okay, I'm being blown up. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And here's one thing you need to know about General Winfield, Scott. Okay. When the war broke out, he was 75 years old. Oh, Lord. That's in 1861, those are some road miles on 70. Yeah, like, he was a veteran of the war of 1812.
于是他意识到，好吧，我这是被晾在一边了。没错，没错，没错。关于温菲尔德·斯科特将军，有一点你必须了解。好吧。战争爆发时，他已经75岁了。哦，天哪。在1861年，对一个70多岁的人来说，这可是饱经风霜了。是的，比如，他是1812年战争的老兵。
His nickname, just so you know that he wasn't in early. adopter. It was old fussing feathers. Oh my goodness. So Lo goes back to the White House. He says, he tells him that, you know, General Scott could not be seen on official business, even at the president's suggestion. Lincoln looked at me a moment, laughed. He rose, seized his tall silk hat, and bade me, come on. And so they walked out of the White House. And they walked over to the General's headquarters. This time the General's Guard turned and announced the President of the United States. Everybody suddenly saluting. And this is Lowe quoting Lincoln. General, this is my friend,
为了让你知道他不是个积极拥抱新事物的人，他的绰号是：“老小题大做”（Old Fuss and Feathers）。我的天哪。于是洛回到白宫。他告诉林肯，温菲尔德·斯科特将军甚至在总统建议的情况下也无法接见因公来访的人。林肯看了我一会儿，大笑了。他站起来，拿起他那顶高高的丝质礼帽，对我说：“走吧。”于是他们走出了白宫。他们步行来到了将军的指挥部。这一次，将军的卫兵转身通报了美利坚合众国总统。所有人立刻敬礼。这是洛引用的林肯的话：“将军，这是我的朋友，
Professor Lowe, who is organizing an aeronautic corps for the army and is to be its chief. I wish you would facilitate his work in every way and give him all the necessary things to equip his branch of the service on land and on water. And with that, he leaves. And suddenly, Thaddeus Lowe is the chief aeronaut of the United States Balloon Corps in service to the federal army. Thaddeus gets to work right away. He oversees the building of seven hydrogen balloons specifically for the army. And he personally takes the first balloon, aptly named Union, through extensive testing.
洛教授，他正在为军队组建一个航空兵团，并将担任总指挥。我希望你们能全力为他的工作提供便利，并提供所有必要物资，在陆上和水上装备好他负责的这个兵团。”说完，他就离开了。就这样，塔迪乌斯·洛成为了美国陆军气球兵团的首席航空长，为联邦军队效力。塔迪乌斯立刻投入了工作。他监督建造了七个专门为军队使用的氢气球。并且他亲自带着那个恰如其分地命名为“联邦号”（Union）的第一只气球进行了广泛的测试。
By the fall of 1861, the kinks have been worked out. and everything is in place. Thaddeus and his balloon corps are ready to launch on the battlefield. How did the soldiers perceive these balloons? Well, they were terrifying when the Confederates realized what these things were, that these were observatory balloons. They would shoot at them. In fact, at first, it was like, you know, ignorant Romans perceiving Hannibal's elephants.
到了1861年秋天，各种故障都已排除，一切就绪。塔迪乌斯和他的气球兵团准备在战场上投入使用了。士兵们是如何看待这些气球的呢？嗯，当南方邦联军队意识到这些东西是什么——意识到这些是侦察气球时，它们简直令人恐惧。他们会向气球开枪。事实上，起初，这种情形就像……你知道的，就像愚昧的罗马人面对汉尼拔的大象一样。
You know, it's like, oh, my God, what are these? And they just unleash of, you know, the isolations of fire. on these balloons, but of course their guns couldn't even mile up. They couldn't reach anywhere close. And in fact, Lowe sort of took delight in the fact that the Confederates were just, you know, using up all their ammo on his balloons. Just like that, Thadius had found a purpose for the purposeless gas bag. And if you can believe it, as chief of the first aerial component of the U.S. military, he was going to have a direct impact on the war. In fact, Thaddeus was regularly breaking new ground. First, there was the time Thaddeus and his men attached one of the balloons to an old coal barge.
你知道，就像，“哦，天哪，这些是什么怪物？”然后他们向这些气球倾泻密集的火力，但当然，他们的枪甚至连一英里的高度都打不到。它们根本够不着任何接近的高度。事实上，洛甚至感到有些好笑，因为南方邦联军队竟然把所有的弹药都浪费在了他的气球上。就这样，塔迪乌斯为这个原本毫无用处的庞大气球找到了用武之地。如果你敢相信的话，作为美国军队第一支空中力量的指挥官，他将对这场战争产生直接的影响。事实上，塔迪乌斯不断开创新的先河。首先，有一次塔迪乌斯和他的手下把其中一个气球绑在了一艘旧煤驳船上。
And they moved it up and down the Potomac River so they could move their balloon into place, up and down in different battles along the edge of this river. That barge is still referred to by some historians as the first aircraft carrier. Then, one day, when Thaddeus was doing his regular reconnaissance, he rose into the air and from his vantage point saw a group of men on horseback behind Confederate lines. Now, what that typically meant was somebody important, right? Officers were on horseback. And so he sent word down the line, aim your cannons over here. There's a bunch of officers over here bombard here. And they do, they come close but miss.
他们拉着它在波托马克河上下移动，这样他们就能把气球移动到位，在沿河的各个战场上来回部署。这艘驳船至今仍被一些历史学家称为第一艘航空母舰。然后，有一天，当塔迪乌斯正在进行例行侦察时，他升入空中，从他的有利位置看到南方邦联军队防线后面有一群骑马的人。通常这意味着有重要人物，对吧？军官们都是骑马的。于是他向地面发出了信号：“把大炮瞄准这里。这里有一群军官，朝这里开炮轰炸。”他们照做了，炮弹落得很近但打偏了。
And those guys scatter. And years afterwards, in a century war book, General James Longstreet wrote a little passage about how at one point they were amazed because President Jefferson Davis, General Robert E. Lee, General James Longstreet, probably Stonewell Jackson, too. We're all there with their staff at this one moment. And then he writes, it was impossible for the enemy to see us as we sat on our horses in this little field surrounded by tall heavy timber and thick undergrowth. And yet a battery by chance had our rain.
那些人四散奔逃。多年后，詹姆斯·隆斯特雷特将军在一部百年战争著作中写了一小段文字，讲述了有一次他们有多么震惊，因为杰斐逊·戴维斯总统、罗伯特·李将军、詹姆斯·隆斯特雷特将军，可能还有斯通沃尔·杰克逊，都在那一刻与他们的参谋人员聚在一起。然后他写道：“敌人根本不可能看到我们，当时我们正骑在马背上，身处这片四周环绕着高大茂密树木和厚重灌木丛的小田野里。然而，一门炮台却偶然间测准了我们的射程，
in our exact distance and poured upon us a terrifying fire. But it was not by chance. So not by chance. And if those shots had connected, the war would have ended. Oh, my God. In fact, the gas bag was so successful that the South tried to copy it. The South had to respond. You know, there was an arms race of sorts, right?
锁定了我们的精确距离，并向我们倾泻了可怕的火力。”但那可不是偶然。所以，绝非偶然。如果那些炮弹击中了目标，战争早就结束了。哦，天哪。事实上，气球大获成功，以至于南方也试图效仿。南方不得不作出回应。你知道，这算是一场军备竞赛，对吧？
Now, of course, they didn't have, you know, trade with the South. There was no more foreign trade, right? So they couldn't get materials easily. And so rather scandalously, they appropriated or was donated all of the petticoat material by the ladies of the South. So all the foundation garments and other bits would have to be sacrificed for the greater good. So they didn't have any silk. And so therefore they made their underwear balloon. It was the underwear balloon.
当然，他们当时跟南方没有贸易往来。再也没有对外贸易了，对吧？所以他们无法轻易获得物资。于是，颇具丑闻意味的是，他们挪用了或由南方女士们捐赠了所有的衬裙布料。所以所有的内衣面料和其他零碎都必须为了更大的利益而牺牲。因此他们没有任何丝绸。于是，他们制造了他们的内衣气球。这就是内衣气球。
You know, the Souther's claim, I mean, they got angry about this, by the way later. Not a single Southern Bell was asked to give up her Sunday best for the cause, said one. And of course, these were bolts of dress material before they were made into actual clothes. But this petticoat balloon finally gets launched. The arms races on. They bring the balloon up to Richmond in 1862, and they put it in action. And Lowe's balloon was also in that fight. So they had two observation balloons at the same time.
你知道，南方人声称——顺便说一句，他们后来对此感到很愤怒。其中一人说，没有一个南方名媛被要求为大义放弃她最好的星期日礼服。当然，这些在被制成实际服装之前原本就是成卷的连衣裙布料。但这个衬裙气球最终还是升空了。军备竞赛开始了。他们在1862年把气球带到了里士满，并将其投入使用。而洛的气球当时也在那场战斗中。所以他们同时拥有两个观察气球。
Your official military historians will say this is the first air-to-air combat. The union eventually captured the balloon and gave it to Thaddeus. And they cut him up into little squares, and every congressman in the north was given one of these little squares of the petticoat. You know, there's another stunt to sort of like increase the funding for the balloon corps. Despite the failure of the petticoat balloon, Thadius's core remained incredibly successful. No union balloon was ever shot down and no balloon core aeronaut was ever killed. But strangely, you know, and this is true of all new sort of inventions. There's a set of people that just simply don't care how good it is.
你们的官方军事历史学家会说这是历史上第一次空战。联邦最终缴获了这个气球，并把它送给了塔迪乌斯。他们把它剪成小方块，北方每一位国会议员都分到了这种衬裙布料的小方块。你知道，这是为了增加气球兵团经费而搞的另一个噱头。尽管衬裙气球失败了，但塔迪乌斯的兵团仍然获得了巨大的成功。没有一个联邦气球被击落，也没有一个气球兵团的航空员牺牲。但奇怪的是，你知道的——所有新发明都是如此——总有一部分人根本不在乎它有多好用。
They like the old way. And strangely, despite all of its successes, it just kind of faded from use by 1863 and kind of disappeared. Like still in the war, it faded from use. Oh, yeah. Yeah, by the end of 62, it was pretty much out of business. After all that, Thaddeus's balloons were grounded. But he carried on doing what he did best, using his failures as a launching pad to the next big thing.
他们就是喜欢老方法。奇怪的是，尽管取得了种种成功，到1863年，它还是逐渐淡出了使用，销声匿迹了。在战争还在进行的时候，它就淡出了使用？哦，是的。是的，到62年底，它基本就已经停业了。在那之后，塔迪乌斯的氣球被迫停飞。但他继续做他最擅长的事，把失败当作通往下一个伟大成就的跳板。
At this point, you know, the war ends and Thaddeus does what you do in peacetime, which is he decides to make money. Some people decided to make money during wartime, too. Oh, they did. That's true. That's very famously, there are those. Thaddeus took everything he learned from his balloonist days and turned them into two huge money-making opportunities. First, Thaddeus took what he learned about heating up gas on the fly for the battlefield and turned that into what would become the first home gas heaters. He brought gas into the house to heat homes better than firewood, better than coal. So the Lowe's Gas Works made a fortune. Then Thaddeus turned his sights from heating to cooling. Remember that Cincinnati balloon ride.
此时此刻，你知道，战争结束了，塔迪乌斯做你在和平时期会做的事，那就是决定赚钱。也有人在战争期间决定赚钱。哦，他们确实这么做了。那是真的。非常著名的是，确实有这样的人。塔迪乌斯把他从气球飞行员生涯中学到的一切转化成了两个巨大的赚钱机会。首先，塔迪乌斯把他从战场上即兴加热气体中学到的知识，转化为了后来成为第一代家用燃气取暖器的技术。他把燃气引入室内，用来给房屋取暖，效果比柴火更好，比煤炭更好。因此，洛氏燃气公司发了大财。接着，塔迪乌斯把目光从供暖转向了制冷。还记得那次辛辛那提的气球之旅吗？
In the strange world of the upper atmosphere, Thaddeus observed a phenomenon up there that he couldn't explain. At night, the balloon would groan and sort of almost breathe. And occasionally when it did, sort of a bushel of ice would come crashing down on his head. And he later discovered that the balloon would go up and down. moisture would, you know, freeze on the inside of the balloon. It attaches just like a glass of iced tea out on a summer porch. The moisture inside the balloon would stick to the balloon. And then when it got a little closer to the earth or warmed up in some way,
在高层大气奇异的世界里，塔迪乌斯在那里观察到了一种他无法解释的现象。到了晚上，气球会发出呻吟声，几乎像是在呼吸。每当它这样做时，偶尔会有一堆冰块哗啦啦地砸在他的头上。他后来发现，气球在上下升降时，水分会……在气球内部结冰。它就像夏天门廊上的一杯冰茶一样凝结在一起。气球内部的水分会附着在气球上。然后，当它离地面更近一点或者某种程度上变暖时，
all of that would loosen and come showering down on Thadis Lowe's head. So that gave him the idea that maybe you could make ice on land, you know. And so he starts the Citizens Ice Company. and I think it's the first public ice company. Wow. And of course, that makes a fortune. Oh, my God. He became so fabulously rich.
所有这些冰就会松动，像阵雨一样倾泻在塔迪乌斯·洛的头上。这给了他一个灵感：也许你可以在地面上人工造冰，你知道的。于是他创办了市民制冰公司。我认为这是第一家公共制冰公司。哇。当然，这让他大发横财。哦，天哪。他变得极其富有。
He started the Citizens Bank of Los Angeles. Needless to say, he'd moved to the West Coast. Yeah. Where everybody goes once they make their money or want to make even more money. In California, he uses that money in a distinctly fattiest way, not to buy a house or a boat, but to take over an entire mountain. Oak Mountain, just north of Los Angeles, which even becomes known as Mount Low. Seriously, look at a map. It's still called that today.
他创办了洛杉矶市民银行。不用说，他已经搬到了西海岸。是的。那是每个人赚了钱、或者想赚更多钱之后都会去的地方。在加州，他以一种极具塔迪乌斯风格的方式使用这笔财富——不是去买房子或买船，而是买下了一整座山。奥克山（Oak Mountain），位于洛杉矶正北方，后来甚至被称为“洛山”（Mount Lowe）。说真的，查查看地图。今天它依然叫这个名字。
His plan was to create something that would bring the sky-high experience to the masses, a resort on the top of the world. What's really cool about the Mount Low Resort is getting to the top of a mountain was not something most people ever did. Yeah, yeah. I think that he was wanted to share that balloon experience. Right? Being at the edge of the world, right? The outer edge. And so he created this large finicular train, you know, the kind that goes up to steep slope. And I've seen pictures of this
他的计划是创造一种能把高空体验带给大众的东西——一个世界之巅的度假村。洛山度假村真正酷的地方在于，登上山顶并不是大多数人以前能做到的事情。是的，是的。我认为他一直想分享那种气球体验。对吧？身处世界的边缘，对吧？最外缘。于是他修建了这条大型缆车轨道，你知道那种爬坡很陡的缆车。我见过这辆缆车的照片。
finicular. You know, I feel perfectly safe for some reason in a finicular. But this trolley car, oh my God. I mean, Dr. Seuss could not have drawn it more rickety. I would never even get anywhere close to this trolley car. But it would take you to Mount Low's Alpine Tavern hotel. And there was a casino there, there was a zoo up there. At night, there was this massive searchlight that they had appropriated from a World's Fair that they could shine and you could see downtown Los Angeles, you know, daytime, you could see the Pacific Ocean from up there. And he sort of democratized the entire sort of experience of what he had done in that balloon. Yeah, yeah. But building a mountaintop resort isn't cheap, no matter what you've invented.
你知道，出于某种原因，我在缆车里觉得绝对安全。但这辆有轨电车，天哪。我的意思是，苏斯博士也画不出比这更破旧的缆车了。我绝对不会靠近这辆有轨电车一步。但它会把你带到洛山高山酒馆酒店。那里有一个赌场，上面还有一个动物园。到了晚上，那里有一个他们从世界博览会上弄来的巨型探照灯，可以照亮夜空，你可以看到洛杉矶市中心；白天，你从那里可以看到太平洋。他某种程度上把他在气球里的那种体验彻底平民化了。是的，是的。但建造一个山顶度假村可不便宜，无论你发明了什么。
And before long, Thadius's relentless ambition had once again gotten the better of him. He went bankrupt, sort of right around the turn of the 20th century, lost all of his money. You know, he longed to be buried at Arlington for his service in the war. And they said, you know, that's only for enlisted soldiers. And you were just some made-up dude called an aeronauts, no. And so he's kind of fading at the turn of the century. But his image as to who he was, this icon of invention and, kind of eccentricity was very much in the air. And, you know, you won't find this in any history
不久之后，塔迪乌斯那永无止境的野心再次害了他。他在20世纪之交前后破产了，输光了所有的钱。你知道，他渴望因为自己在战争中的服役而被安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓。而他们说，“你知道，那是留给应征士兵的。你只是个自封的、叫什么航空员的家伙，不行。”所以他在世纪之交时有点黯然失色。但他作为一个人物的形象——这个发明与古怪特质的偶像——依然在空气中弥漫。而且，你知道，你在任何历史
book, but I'll put this to you. Okay. So 1900 is the year that L. Frank Baum wrote his book. Yeah. The Wizard of Oz. So the titular character is in the beginning of the book, you know, he is this old man in white hair with insane mustaches, sort of half scientists, half crackpot con man. And then in the dream world of that book, you know, he becomes the showman who invents this whole world and then in the end, you know, jumps in this balloon and flies off. And his last words are, I don't know how to steer this thing. I can see it. You can see it, right? Absolutely, I can see it. Thaddeus Lowe's legacy is hard to pin down, despite his mountain, his many inventions, or even his apparent
书中都找不到这个，但我把它提出来。好吧。1900年是L·弗兰克·鲍姆写下他的书的那一年。是的。《绿野仙踪》。所以书的开头那个同名主角，你知道，他是一个留着白发、蓄着疯狂胡须的老头，某种程度上半是个科学家、半是个江湖骗子的怪杰。然后在那本书的梦幻世界里，你知道，他成了那个创造了整个世界的表演大师，最后，你知道，跳进这个气球飞走了。而他的遗言是：“我不知道怎么驾驶这玩意儿。”我能看出来。你能看出来，对吧？绝对的，我能看出来。塔迪乌斯·洛的遗产很难轻易定义，尽管他拥有自己的山峰、众多的发明，甚至他对经典文学的明显
influence on classic literature, most of us have never heard his name. But I think you can make the argument that his gas bag, his dream, planted the seed for every future attempt to fly higher, from the airplane to the space shuttle. Stay with me here. When we think of air flight, we think about the Wright brothers. But when the Wright brothers thought of air flight, they thought of Thadius Lowe. And in 1910, only seven years after their own pioneering flight, we think about the Wright brothers, The Wright brothers were hosting the first major air show in the U.S., and they specifically invite Thaddeus Lowe to come. You know, because he's the grand old man of air flight, right, and he had sort of institutionalized this, this longing to get out to the farthest, the longest, the fastest. He is the Rand Franklin of the air, and, you know, they want him to come and honor him.
影响，但我们大多数人从未听说过他的名字。但我认为你可以这样认为：他的气球、他的梦想，为人类此后每一次飞得更高的尝试——从飞机到航天飞机——埋下了种子。听我继续说。当我们想到航空飞行时，我们会想到莱特兄弟。但当莱特兄弟考虑航空飞行时，他们想到的是塔迪乌斯·洛。在1910年，也就是他们自己进行开创性飞行仅仅七年之后，我们想到莱特兄弟，莱特兄弟正在美国举办第一场盛大的航空展，他们特意邀请了塔迪乌斯·洛前来参加。你知道，因为他是航空界的元老级人物，而且他某种程度上将这种渴望——飞向最远、最久、最快的地方——制度化了。他是航空界的兰·富兰克林，而且，你知道，他们希望他来并向他致敬。
And so he goes. And he has a granddaughter named Florence Leontine Lowe. She is eight years old. And in one of the exhibits, there is this sort of cartoon-like display with like movable airplanes. And, you know, they knew that Thaddeus Lowe was going to bring his granddaughter. So they had a cartoon cutout of Florence in the airplane as the pilot. Yeah. Nice.
于是他去了。他有一个孙女叫弗洛伦斯·莱昂蒂娜·洛。她八岁大。在其中一个展品中，有一个类似卡通风格的展示，带有可移动的飞机模型。而且，你知道，他们知道塔迪乌斯·洛会带着他的孙女来。所以他们做了一个弗洛伦斯坐在飞机里当飞行员的卡通纸板剪影。是的。不错。
Before long, Florence would pick up where her grandfather left off. And it's through Florence that I'm going to let Jack just trace the long tale of Thadis' legacy. though by her adulthood she wasn't called Florence anymore. She was called Poncho Barnes. She dressed as a man, smoked cigars, and she gets her pilot's license in 1928. And at that time, a lot of air experimentation was done by women, as much as men. It's not just Amelia Earhart, whom we've all heard out.
不久之后，弗洛伦斯将承袭她祖父未竟的事业。正是通过弗洛伦斯，我要让杰克来追溯塔迪乌斯传奇的漫长延续。不过到她成年时，她不再叫弗洛伦斯了。她叫庞cho·巴恩斯（Pancho Barnes）。她穿着男装，抽着雪茄，并在1928年获得了飞行员执照。在那个时代，很多航空实验都是由女性完成的，丝毫不逊于男性。不仅有我们都听说过的阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特。
In fact, Poncho, we'll now call her, became the first female stunt pilot in Hollywood. Oh my goodness. She broke Amelia Earhart's speed record. She clocked 196.199 miles per hour. That's amazing. And after breaking that record, Poncho turned a patch of land in the desert into the destination for Hollywood Starlets, test pilots, and anybody else who wanted to land their plane somewhere where they would be guaranteed a good time. The resort quickly became a notorious party destination that Poncho named the Happy Bottom Riding Club.
事实上，庞cho——我们现在这样称呼她——成了好莱坞第一位女性特技飞行员。哦，天哪。她打破了阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特的速度纪录。她创下了每小时196.199英里的时速。太惊人了。打破纪录后，庞cho把沙漠中的一块土地变成了一个目的地，吸引了无数好莱坞新星、试飞员以及任何想要将飞机降落在某个能保证玩得开心的地方的人。这个度假村迅速成了一个臭名昭著的派对胜地，庞cho把它命名为“快乐屁股骑马俱乐部”（Happy Bottom Riding Club）。
It became the hangout after World War II. And people would come out there and go horseback riding, but there would also be these wild parties at night. And, you know, anyone who broke a record got a free steak dinner in the restaurant, you know, was that kind of thing. So everybody hung out there. Chuck Yeager was one of the big attendees there. Chuck Yeager, the first pilot in history to break the sound barrier. By the way, great little story that I think he tells years later, but the night before he broke the sound barrier. He went for a midnight ride with Poncho and some others at the Happy Bottom Riding Club.
它成了二战后人们的聚会场所。人们会到那里去骑马，但到了晚上也会有各种疯狂的派对。而且，你知道，任何打破纪录的人都能在餐馆里享用免费的牛排晚餐，你知道，就是那种风格的地方。所以每个人都在那里闲逛。查克·耶格尔（Chuck Yeager）就是那里的常客之一。查克·耶格尔，历史上第一个突破音障的飞行员。顺便说一句，有一个很棒的小故事，我想那是他多年后讲述的，就在他打破音障的前一晚，他跟庞cho和其他人一起去快乐屁股骑马俱乐部进行了一场午夜骑马。
and someone had closed a gate and they couldn't see it on the way back. So the horse hit it and he flew off and broke a couple of his ribs. And so when he did his famous test flight the next day, he had several broken ribs. If he had told anybody, he would not have been. No, that would have been stripped, yeah. And when he got into the cock could, I think somebody noticed that he closed the thing with his left hand because he couldn't use his right hand. Despite the groundbreaking achievement, Yeager wouldn't become an astronaut like the other test pilots.
有人关了门，他们在回来的路上看不见。所以马撞了上去，他飞了出去，断了好几根肋骨。因此，当他第二天进行著名的试飞时，他有几根肋骨骨折了。如果他告诉任何人，他就不会被允许飞行。不，那会被剥夺资格的，是的。当他进入驾驶舱时，我想有人注意到他用左手关了门，因为他无法使用右手。尽管取得了突破性的成就，耶格尔并没有像其他试飞员那样成为宇航员。
largely because he didn't have a college degree. But he did train them. In fact, he trained one of the ones that went to the moon. When I was little, everybody, of course, we all loved Neil Armstrong. He was handsome and tall and brave. And Buzz Aldrin, he was talkative and cocky. He was called Buzz. He was called Buzz.
主要是因为他没有大学学位。但他确实培训了他们。事实上，他培训过登月宇航员之一。当我小的时候，当然，我们所有人都很喜欢尼尔·阿姆斯特朗。他又帅又高又勇敢。而巴兹·奥尔德林，他很健谈而且有点傲慢。他被称为巴兹。他被称为巴兹。
But it wasn't Neil Armstrong or Buzz Aldrin that Yeager trained. It was Jack Hitt's personal favorite. the one almost everyone forgets. There's a third guy, Mike Collins, the other guy. And that's interesting that all of his life, he explained that there was only one question that he ever got to ask. And that was what it was like to be as far away from Earth as anyone has ever been. Because that was his achievement, right?
但耶格尔培训的不是尼尔·阿姆斯特朗或巴兹·奥尔德林。那是杰克·希特的最爱，那个几乎被所有人遗忘的人。还有第三个人，迈克·科林斯，另一个人。有趣的是，他一生中都在解释说，他只被问过一个问题。那就是，身处距离地球像任何人曾经去过的地方那么远是一种什么样的体验。因为那是他的成就，对吧？
That was his thing. As Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin left to walk on the moon, Mike Collins was the one who had to stay behind on the spacecraft. And in the module, he would orbit the moon, traveling the farthest from earth that anyone ever had. And he did so alone. Because remember, when he turns the corner, when he goes around to the dark side of the moon, he's out of radio contact. And there's no light, right? There is nothing. He can see nothing. He's in this tin camp. And he originally answered the question, outside my window, I can see stars, and that is all. Where I know the moon, will be there is simply a black void. The moon's presence is defined solely by the absence of the
那是他的标志。当尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和巴兹·奥尔德林出发去月球漫步时，迈克·科林斯是那个不得不留在飞船上的人。在舱内，他将绕月轨道飞行，到达比任何人曾经去过的地方还要远的地球外侧。而且他是独自一人。因为记住，当他转过弯，绕到月球背面时，他就失去了无线电联系。而且没有光，对吧？什么也没有。他什么也看不见。他就在这个锡罐里。他最初回答这个问题时说，在我的窗外，我可以看到星星，仅此而已。我知道月亮应该在的地方只是一片黑色的虚空。月亮的存在完全由星星的缺失来定义。
stars. I am alone now. Truly alone and absolutely isolated from any known life. I am it. If a count were taken, the score would be $3 billion plus two over on the other side of the moon. And one plus God knows what on this side. Collins was alone, surrounded by an inky blackness, punctuated only by stars. Wow. I mean, what you're describing is very much the scene of Thaddeus Lowe taking off an unelectrified world for his flight. Absolutely. Lowe's description of the sky and the sensation of being out there, you know, three and a half, four miles above the earth,
我现在孤身一人。真正的孤独，与任何已知生命绝对隔绝。只有我。如果数一数，月球另一边有三十亿加两个人。而这一边只有一个人加上上帝才知道是什么。科林斯孤零零的，周围是一片漆黑的墨色，只有星星点缀其间。哇。我的意思是，你所描绘的非常像塔迪乌斯·洛夫为了他的飞行离开一个没有电气化的世界的场景。绝对是。洛夫对天空的描述以及身处其中的感觉，你知道的，距离地球三英里半、四英里高空，
It seems so very close to what Mike Collins is describing, you know, hundreds of thousands of miles above the air. Collins was weightless in his gravity-free capsule, floating like Thaddeus and his balloon all those years earlier. Despite being separated by more than a century, these two men were experiencing the same thing. One in a wicker basket over Cincinnati and the other in a tin can on the dark side of the moon. And it was the exact same instinct that it led both the aeronaut and the astronaut to take to the skies. It seems like specifically a very American obsession to try to push their way to the outer edge of something, that whole frontier mentality that has kind of been with us from the beginning. This is great, Jack Hitt.
这似乎非常接近迈克·科林斯所描述的，你知道的，距离空气数十万英里高的地方。科林斯在他的无重力太空舱里处于失重状态，像多年前的塔迪乌斯和他的气球一样漂浮着。尽管相隔一个多世纪，这两个人却在经历着同样的事情。一个在辛辛那提上空的藤条篮里，另一个在月球背面的锡罐里。正是这种完全相同的本能，引导着航空员和宇航员飞向蓝天。这似乎是一种非常美国式的执念，试图冲向某事物的边缘，那种从一开始就伴随着我们的开拓精神。这太棒了，杰克·希特。
Thank you so much for talking with me. I just had a delightful time. Great. Me too. Jack Hitt is an author and contributing editor of Harper's, The New York Times Magazine, and This American Life. If you like this story about Thaddeus Lowe, you should check out Jack's book, Bunch of Amateurs, which is an inside look at the inventors, tinkerers, and other eccentrics whose creations have made America what it is today.
非常感谢你与我交谈。我度过了一段非常愉快的时光。太棒了。我也是。杰克·希特是一位作家，也是《哈泼斯杂志》、《纽约时报杂志》和《这个美国生活》的特约编辑。如果你喜欢这个关于塔迪乌斯·洛夫的故事，你应该去看看杰克的书《业余爱好者》，这本书深入剖析了那些发明家、修补匠和其他怪才，正是他们的创造造就了今天的美国。
A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Isaac Fisher. Our other producers are Ellie Lightfoot, Brenna Daldorf, and Priscilla Al-Bee. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2.
《美国简史与100件物品》是99%隐形和BBC工作室联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马斯主持和策划。本集由艾萨克·费舍尔制作。我们的其他制作人是埃莉·莱特富特、布伦娜·达尔多夫和普iscilla·阿尔-比。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。艾米·布拉克顿负责事实核查。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99%隐形节目，我们的执行制作人是凯茜2。
From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Sirius XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自BBC工作室，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特，艺术设计由斯特凡·劳伦斯负责。99%隐形节目是天狼星XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。BBC工作室总部位于西伦敦美丽的白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物件让我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至100 Objects at 99PI.org。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。